to absolutely no one's surprise or at
least to non- diard MCU fans the
Marvel's is flat out bad your enjoyment
will obviously vary off of purely how
much fun you have with the movie and how
much of the humor lands for you
personally because at the end of the day
that sort of thing is extremely
subjective but for this review I'm going
to primarily be analyzing the quality of
the character work plots and overall
writing and why I think it's a failure
because to me those are the most
important aspects that make me
fundamentally care about a D some jokes
in a happy tone with a fast pace won't
make me automatically love a movie and I
can see why people can enjoy this
significantly more than something like
secret Invasion so the biggest and most
flawed aspect to me was the character
work out of the collection of characters
within the movie between Carol Danvers
Monica Rambo Camala Khan Nick Fury and
the villain there was only one character
that actually felt well executed which
was Kamala Khan Iman fani breathes so
much energy and Charisma into Camala
that she's always an extremely endearing
and lovable character her bubbly and
fangirly Persona gives the character so
much life to the point that the contrast
between Monica and Carol feels massive
although that kind of dynamic between
these characters is pretty likable
because of the sheer difference in
energy and personality however I think
this also exposes how much of a Charisma
sync both Carol and Monica are as
characters or even actors Carol I would
say is a bit more likable here than in
her own movie and she's showing some
personality but she still comes across
as being pretty bland and the same thing
applies for Monica they're supposed to
be the more grounded and serious
characters however the movie doesn't
offer enough depth for them to really
become interesting for Cala you care so
much about her because she's still a kid
and there are Stakes for her well-being
because her family cares about her along
with her vibrant and unique perspective
of absolutely loving becoming a
superhero with her literal hero growing
up it energizes her with the significant
likeability that Monica and Carol come
nowhere close to because the only thing
those two characters have is a minor
past conflict in that Carol never came
back to help raise Monica so since that
development is awkwardly dealt with and
is basically breezed over within a few
minutes of it being brought up there's
really nothing that the movie does to
make you care about these two other main
characters that's why I think Camala
absolutely carries the film without
going into spoilers there's this past
action that Carol did that comes back to
haunt her but the movie doesn't really
dive into that and is only dealt with at
a surface level the writers could have
done a lot more internally and
emotionally to make Harold daners a
significantly more relatable character
like she may be this Unstoppable Godlike
figure but these major choices she's
making have consequences and she has to
personally deal with the heavy guilt
associated with that however the movie
essentially briefly brushes over this
and doesn't do much with that to make
Carol a more interesting character so to
me one of the three leads was enjoyable
while the other two came across as being
Bland in mostly dull from here it gets
significantly worse because the handling
of Nick Fury and the villain were truly
horrendous Nick Fury is literally
delegated as a comedic relief character
as 95% of his screen time is just making
quips and jokes this is obviously very
jarring especially coming off a secret
invasion in which Nick Fury is supposed
to have his groove back and I assume be
at least kind of serious but nope that's
not the case at all every single moment
he's used to Rattle off jokes and to be
honest some of them landed because I
love Samuel Jackson but the entire time
it was happening I couldn't help but
think the writers were ruining the
character he's slowly being corrupted
for short-term comedic value as this
brutally serious character turns into a
fluffy teddy bear there's really not
much else done with his character as he
kind of just meanders around in a
background subplot which I'll get into
in a minute then finally we have the
villain now Marvel is extremely
inconsistent with their villain quality
where they could either make complete
complete masterpieces like Loki or
Thanos or they can make atrocities and
the villain who I don't even remember
her name which is honestly really sad
apparently her name is Dar Ben is sadly
in the atrocity tier it didn't even feel
like the writers tried to make her a
compelling villain she's just a bland
comically bad person who has a
motivation that is so devoid of logic
that I don't think it really constitutes
as a spoiler so I'll go into it for this
segment I'm going to talk about the
villain's motivation which is that Carol
ver does an action that negatively
impacts a planet and now the sun is
dying I don't remember exactly why that
is the case since it was explained
pretty quickly or if it even was at all
but the first major thing that wouldn't
make sense about this is that if your
sun is dying then your planet's
temperature would plummet thus
destroying the population because the
movie visually shows the sun is being
almost extinguished and if that was the
case I'm sure the planet would be
uninhabitable but it's not people are
living on it and also without an
atmosphere I'm pretty sure in the
beginning of the movie so to me at least
the entire motivation surrounding the
villain is nonsensical because it
doesn't make sense so that paired with a
villain that has barely any screen time
is monotonous and the creators gave her
like 1 minute of backstory makes her one
of the weakest villains in the MCU every
character besides Kamala feels deeply
flawed or doesn't have enough happening
internally to make them intriguing which
to me is by far the biggest failure in
that by having an uninteresting main
character and villain it makes the story
completely unengaging both the driving
force of the film and the overall
conflict doesn't Captivate the audience
so the only thing that does is the humor
and fun tone and even though Calo is a
clear standup because of this I think
the creators realized that and
relentlessly use her high energy in
almost every moment of the film to the
point that it kind of burned me out
which I still like her but she can't
always be DED up to 11 there needs to be
some kind of balance for the character
and at times I do find that balance
while in others she can feel over
utilized so ironically this movie feels
more centered around Camala even though
Carol damers is the main character
moving away from the characters let's
address the main selling point of the
movie which is the quantum entanglement
now all the science fiction Exposition
is rattled off so quickly to the point
that I don't expect they cared if the
audience really understood it which is
fine to a degree because with a vague
scientific statement that sounds half
accurate I can buy this as being real
within the Universe however what
immediately drives me crazy is if said
mechanic is extremely inconsistent in
how it works so in essence if one of
these three characters use their power
they switch places with someone else I
assume it's random and there's not a
link between certain characters now the
inconsistency arrives in the fact that
in almost every single scene one of our
characters uses their powers and doesn't
trade places with another character
they'll simply be using it to fight
someone casually as if there's no
entanglement happening which is an utter
contradiction at one point during a
training montage they established that
if they keep using their power in a
sustained sense after teleporting then
they won't immediately do it again it
was explained very fast and I wish I
could rewatch it but they constantly
stop using their power and then use it
again or they'll just be using their
power no teleportation happens so
overall this leads to a completely
inconsistent usage of the teleporting
mechanic to the point that it just feels
like the creators are doing it whenever
they feel like it this aspect was really
having me crazy and since this mechanic
was kind of a mystery for the characters
they couldn't actually explain it so you
just have to roll with it and accept how
it's used in the movie despite it being
confusing and contradictory this leads
into another major flaw in that it makes
some of the action scenes jarring
specifically the ending scene in which
all three characters are attacking the
villain simultaneously with their powers
it becomes really hard to follow the
action because the scene both has really
fast-paced editing with Quick Cuts has
the teleporting mechanic randomly kick
kicking in and four characters all
fighting at once the action because of
this quickly becomes overwhelming and
thus is why I think it's pretty jarring
there is one action scene towards the
beginning of the movie in which the
three main characters are in different
locations as they fight three separate
battles that was more digestible since
each set piece had a single hero
fighting at a single time but again the
teleporting mechanic quickly became
erratic and how it was used so the big
issue here is that this was one of the
major selling points of the movie and I
think it was handled pretty poorly even
though I did partially enjoy that first
action scene now going into the plot of
the movie there are certain parts about
it that I want to address firstly this
isn't really a spoiler but there is a
portion of this movie that is dedicated
to the Scrolls given that secret
Invasion sets up there being peace talks
with the cre now the first thing that is
immediately contradicting is that there
are scroll outposts on different planets
I thought the entire conundra and secret
invasion was that they couldn't find any
habitable planet which is is stupid and
of itself and they had to go to Earth
which is inherently a contrivance to
instill a false sense of conflict on
Earth however here through an utter
contradiction the scrolls are living on
other planets albeit to a small degree I
guess so this entire Dynamic with the
Scrolls is confusing because of this
along with us not knowing these specific
Scrolls so the politics between them and
the cre just led me to not care I'd
assume a character like Gaia would be
greatly involved with this kind of
conflict considering that she's just a
more op version of Captain Marvel but I
doubt the writers would even consider
that so this entire chunk of the movie
felt very underdeveloped and the Scrolls
then evaporate out of the movie The only
redeeming aspect about this sequence is
that it introduces a character flaw for
Carol and that her actions can have
negative consequences and she isn't this
Almighty being who can only do good even
though as I said before I don't think
the writers explore that angle of her
character enough then before going into
the main plot there are two set pieces
that will primarily be talked about a
lot one of them is a planet in which the
only language people speak is singing
although they are singing in English but
they don't understand English if it's
not in song format so yeah to put simply
this feels like the writers were high
and we trying to come up with a quirky
gimmick for a planet and it didn't land
for me at all then for the second it's
tied directly to Nick Fury subplot which
feels largely pointless and I can't
really talk about it in detail because
it spoils the ending of it but talking
about it vaguely it was so crazy and
unhinged from a writing perspective that
I just ironically found it funny it's
going to be polarizing because of how
ridiculous the scene is but I just lost
it especially at the music they used for
the scene so I hate to admit it I kind
of enjoyed that scene the most even
though it was batshit insane and I kind
of respect the writers for doing
something that was that unhinged it made
me laugh but at the expense of breaking
reality but yeah the main plot for the
movie is very stereotypical and plays it
safe the heroes essentially come
together through the first half of the
movie and then they simply overcome the
main conflict at no point is there any
clever writing or story SL plot
subversions and it is mostly a by the
Numbers Marvel movie except it has a
much faster pace which is both a
blessing and kind of a curse in that at
least we got out of the movie Faster and
they also couldn't take a lot of time to
build characters like Carol desperately
needed some more character developments
and I would have been fine if they
slowed down more for that there are
definitely more minor aspects about the
story that are poorly written but I
think I went through the biggest issues
being the badly written characters the
quantum entanglement mechanic being
confusing and inconsistent and the plot
being mediocre with a plethora of dumb
writing beats so I can see why Marvel
fans can have a fun time with this movie
but anyone who's on the fence or isn't
loving the MCU anymore clearly won't
enjoy this movie unlike Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 which was pretty much
universally loved by everyone I'll be
trying to review Loki season 2 as soon
as possible and I actually enjoy that
show I don't purely hate the MCU and I
wish it can be better thank you for
watching and let me know in the comments
what you thought about the
Marvels